It's getting worse and worse for Donald Trump.
Now that Jeffrey Epstein has been arrested
for child sex trafficking.
I told you before, and I reminded you yesterday
that a woman has alleged that when she was
13 years old, Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein
raped her at Epstein's New York City condo.
The lawsuit was ultimately stopped by the
accuser, uh, after she allegedly received
death threats because she had come forward.
Now, Donald Trump has been going very much
out of his way to distance himself from Jeffrey
Epstein as much as possible, despite having
hung out with him a lot in years past.
And he even threw out somebody at his rally
in Minnesota over the weekend for holding
up a picture of Trump with his arm around
Jeffrey Epstein.
I talked about that yesterday.
There's now a stunning report in the New York
Times, which includes the story of a 1992
party at Donald Trump's Maro Lago resort in
Florida, where the only attendees were Donald
Trump.
Jeffrey Epstein and quote 28 girls for some
kind of supposed calendar girl competition.
Now, why am I calling them girls and not women?
Because that's the word that the organizer
used to describe this event.
His name is George Harrain.
He's a Florida businessman who ran American
dream enterprise and he organized this party
for Donald Trump and Jeffrey Epstein saying
to the New York Times quote, I arranged to
have some contestants fly in at the very first
party.
I said, who's coming tonight?
I have 28 girls coming.
It was him and Epstein.
I said, Donald, this is supposed to be a party
with VIP [inaudible].
You're telling me it's you and Epstein and
I want to be really, really careful here to
make clear what I am telling you and what
I am not telling you or what it is that the
New York Times is reporting and what it is,
not that they're reporting.
Uh, there is no indication that any of these
28 women were underage as far as what we know
right now.
Okay.
This is evidence that Donald Trump was truly
friends with Epstein, liked Epstein, liked
hanging out with him, was hanging out with
him and in this case it was just him, Epstein
and 28 hired women or girls as they are described
by George Harrain.
So the big picture is very clear.
The party was in 1992 this is around the same
time that the doe vs Trump incident allegedly
happened where Trump was accused of raping
the 13 year old girl.
I got some emails yesterday from people saying,
David, I'm glad you brought this back up,
but I also got a few emails yesterday saying,
David, why are you repeating these unsubstantiated
conspiracy theories against Trump?
Oh, hold on a second.
There are rape allegations.
The lawsuit was pulled over death threats.
Trump is accused of sexually assaulting more
than 15 women.
He's accused of hanging out with Epstein and
young women.
Trump's wife said that Trump raped her multiple
times.
What is so out of line here about the fact
that we have court documents and deposition
testimony from the accuser of Donald Trump
plumbing.
She was 13 years old when Donald Trump raped
her.
Are you saying that because there was no conviction
in the Trump child rape, there is no reason
to think anything happened that seems like
an extreme position to take.
Incredibly, there are tons and tons of people
who just have no idea about the sworn allegations
against Donald Trump.
But we have sworn statements from the woman
who was 13 at the time.
That has not changed.
We are linking to her deposition video where
her face is blurred in the source links for
the youtube video for this segment.
If you want to take a look at it, if you're
listening on the radio or the podcast or watching
on TV, if you go to our youtube channel, youtube.com/the
David Pakman show, find the video clip for
this story in the description we are linking
to the testimony of the accuser.
Take a look at it and tell me that it's not
credible.
So things not going particularly well for
Donald Trump.
Uh, and we will see what continues to come
of this.
And Donald Trump very clearly worried about
it.
Donald Trump going out of his way to talk
about how he just barely has any idea who,
who Epstein is.
He gave a very strange a oval office, a question
and answer session yesterday where he's just
going way too far.
He's going way too far given what we know
and what's on record about his relationship
with Epstein.
Let me know what you think is going to come
of this.
And of course, if history is an indicator,
the last two and a half years are an indicator.
Uh, it is unlikely that there will ever actually
be any consequences that involve Trump here
because that seems to be the name of the game,
a Teflon Don, uh, originally.
Um, I can't believe the mobster, I always
forget who it is that tough dot.
Teflon Don, uh, was originally the nickname
for, and I feel so stupid when people email
me, but anyway, can also be applied, uh, to
Donald Trump.
Send me your thoughts.
I'm on Twitter at d pacman.
The show is on Twitter at David Pakman show.
I hope you'll follow me there.